[Music]
on this monday night a day of
demonstrations outside canadian
hospitals
protests against pandemic protocols and
vaccine passports our freedom
is
is violated the political pledges to
protect health care workers and patients
the conservatives positive campaign
descends into personal attacks i think
it's a sign of desperation the fight for
progressive voters courting younger
canadians they're unsure about who they
want to vote for their biggest concerns
and the barriers they face plus family
tragedy the discovery of two adults and
four children in a burnt out trailer
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us frontline healthcare workers inside
canada's hospitals have put the
well-being of canadians ahead of their
own throughout the pandemic
so it seems unfathomable that hospitals
are now the target of protests but it's
what's happening today right across the
country the protests coincide with
british columbia implementing a proof of
vaccination certificate that's required
for access to non-essential services and
to attend large events political leaders
are condemning demonstrations that block
medical facilities and intimidate
doctors nurses and patients we'll get to
reaction from the campaign trail in just
a moment but first eric sorenson looks
at who is behind the protests and what
can be done to keep hospitals from
becoming battle lines
they have mounted protests outside
hospitals across the country say no to
the vaccine passport in canada among the
organizers a few health workers
including a nurse who was fired after
being part of an anti-lockdown rally
last year
they're protesting vaccine mandates
being forced they say to take drugs they
don't want it's threatening it's
cajoling it's bullying it's tyranny call
it whatever you like it's wrong really
basic human rights are being violated
they're a fraction of the population but
even small numbers could choke off
access to hospitals or intimidate
workers and patients
one doctor alone sentinel outside a
toronto hospital today stands behind the
science and vaccines that are accepted
by the vast majority of canadians behind
us is sacred ground
this is a place where people come to get
healed where people are sick
and where professionals like myself and
the nurses i work with deserve to be
treated with respect and not intimidated
or harassed he's not alone major health
organizations for nurses and doctors are
calling for safe zones to allow people
into and out of hospitals safely what we
really are hoping for is that
those entryways those exit ways are
maintained that the healthcare workers
that are going in and out of hospitals
are not harassed or abused and
ultimately that they can do their job in
the middle of a pandemic in a meaningful
way it is not the place to protest it is
wrong all the federal leaders condemned
blocking access to health centers today
these protests this harassment of our
front line
nurses doctors is completely
unacceptable the liberals say they'll
pass legislation to make it a crime we
are protecting people
including health care workers
from those who would scream obscenities
at them and spit on them on their way
into work to save lives this health care
worker is blunt to bring this here to
bring this kind of vitriol of where
people have been working flat out
and continue to go nonstop to help
people
it's hard to understand the rationale
the demonstrators have targeted what for
most canadians are cherished
institutions that save lives and if the
protesters themselves get sick and need
help will save their lives too
eric sorensen global news toronto
anti-vaccine and anti-mask protesters
have followed liberal leader justin
trudeau since he called the election
last month and as eric mentioned trudeau
is now promising to crack down on
demonstrations that disrupt hospitals
and health centers but
is a new law necessary abigail beeman is
following the liberal campaign
we need to nourish
celebrate and protect their jobs when
talking about the need to protect people
from kovid justin trudeau often brings
up son hadrian too young for a vaccine
monday he and sophie were by trudeau's
side in vancouver as he announced a
reelected liberal government would make
it illegal to block access to health
care sites with protests at hospitals
across the country it is not ok that
across the country
hospitals are having to put up
barricades
today to manage the mobs coming their
way the promise extends to vaccine
centers and abortion clinics
but it's already illegal to utter
threats or assault someone of course so
it's a new law necessary this is a
mixture of political grandstanding and
the ability to create another wedge
issue with o'toole trudeau certainly
gives him the gears in the release but
it also might be time to clarify this
for police and other people can they be
charged with things already yes
what potentially makes a new provision
necessary or beneficial or as someone
who formerly worked as a law reform
lawyer i would suggest a good idea
is that it sends a signal to the
population it's an idea politically
popular enough that the ndp announced
something similar last week we want to
specifically protect health care workers
by changing the criminal code to make it
an aggravating event an aggravating
element to in any way
impede or assault or enemy threaten a
healthcare worker i don't know if i have
an opinion yet on whether or not it's
necessary but i will say this
some of the images that we saw from the
previous protests are absolutely
heartbreaking
and any measures that help to prevent
that from happening in the future are
absolutely a good thing
trudeau himself was punchy with
protesters who followed him to an
interview at global b.c isn't there a
hospital you should be going to bother
right now monday's announcement is part
of a broader liberal strategy in the
final week to hammer home differences on
wedge issues and the party hope set up a
clear choice between a re-elected
liberal government and their top
opponents in a tight race the
conservatives abigail beeman global news
richmond bc
nbc's new vaccine passport system took
effect today the same day the province
announced it will be mandating
vaccinations for all health care workers
british columbia's top doctor says the
rule will include workers students
physicians residents contractors and
volunteers who work in any health care
facility the order will go into effect
on october 26th
a week or so into the new school year
dangerous outbreaks of covid19 have
already led to school closures in prince
edward island and ontario and today new
brunswick announced all students will be
required to wear masks the goal is to
keep in-person learning going as long as
possible but as heather ux west explains
the highly transmissible delta variant
isn't making it easy
with covid 19 cases now at 11 schools
across the province new brunswick is
changing its back to school plan
effective tomorrow students of all ages
in all schools across new brunswick must
wear a mask in school and while on
school buses in quebec students in 72
schools will now be able to access rapid
tests those rapid tests are
good but they are
complementary to
regular tests pcr regular tests so if
kids
have some symptoms
we highly recommend parents
to keep their kids at home the measure
is designed to offer more layers of
protection for students and their
schools especially as children under 12
remain ineligible for the covet 19
vaccine
children are less likely to become
seriously ill from this virus but some
will and in alberta where overall
infection numbers are soaring more kids
are getting sick the numbers are rising
it used to be we would only see maybe
one or two children presenting for
emergency department care every week and
now we're seeing a handful of them
almost every day with less support from
the provincial government alberta school
districts like the calgary board of
education are now doing things like
contact tracing themselves though in a
letter this week parents were told that
asymptomatic close contacts should keep
coming to school
if you choose to keep your child at home
it will be marked as an unexcused
absence it's really been contradictory
in these statements of what we are
wanting people to do what we are asking
them to do and then how we are enforcing
these provisions creating confusion for
parents in a dangerous time as the delta
variant continues to cause covid 19
cases to rise heather urex west global
news calgary
returning to the campaign trail today
conservative leader erin o'toole focused
less on policy and more on personality
o'toole took some personal jobs against
liberal leader justin trudeau as michael
couture reports the attack strategy
could be an indication that tories
believe their chance at forming
government is slipping away
i have expectations of us running a
positive campaign
in one breath aaron o'toole said he
wants to raise the bar of political
discourse minutes earlier the
conservative leader was focused on
personal attacks not policy every
canadian has met a justin trudeau in
their lives
privileged entitled and always looking
out for number one
this level of mudslinging hasn't been
seen in this election until now that's
how close the race really is with a week
to go but this liberal strategist
believes it shows something else i think
it's a sign of desperation it's a sign
that at this point they are willing to
do anything that they can to fight off
justin trudeau who they recognize is
their main competition liberals the ndp
and conservatives are now vying for
progressive voters monday the tories
pitched a plan to improve maternity and
parental leave programs something last
expanded by the trudeau liberals and
o'toole plans to extend the canada child
benefit aid even before the birth of a
baby policies like the ones that are
announced today certainly are designed
to appeal to
women and young families and i think
that that is really a direct appeal from
the part of the conservatives to have a
bit more of a softer image part of
softening that image is o'toole's
declaration that he is pro-choice and an
ally of the lgbtq2
community however months ago half of the
conservative caucus voted against a ban
on conversion therapy and a majority of
his caucus voted in support of a bill
that sought to restrict certain
abortions leaving some to wonder if
hardline tory backbenchers will really
follow o'toole's lead he can't even get
his party members to all vaccinate who
is to trust that he can get them to vote
the way that he he thinks they should
that's the question the liberals and ndp
want people to be asking themselves as
all parties make their pitch to
progressive voters
farah
michael couture in ottawa thank you mike
throughout the campaign ndp leader
jagmeet singh has shied away from
answering whether he would prop up a
minority government but this morning he
signaled he may be willing to join
forces
i'll do whatever it takes to make sure i
can form government so if i'm in that
position
and i need to work with another party to
form government to achieve the things
that people need we've listed out some
of the things that we've noted that mr
trudeau broke his promises on that ended
up costing people i'm committing to that
it is a tight election race and there's
a good chance we might not even get a
clear result on election night but ahead
of september 20th global national is
working to get the full picture right
across the country we're on the home
stretch of our big road trip across
canada tomorrow global national is
broadcasting from quebec city and donna
friesen joins us from there now hi donna
hi there pharah quebec has 78 ridings
and it is coveted by all the political
parties and quebec city the riding here
has a fascinating history electing a
progressive conservative a block an ndp
and a liberal mp the margin of victory
in that last election less than one
percent there are lots of tight races
here in quebec and now quebec's premier
has weighed in saying he'd prefer a
conservative minority so we'll discuss
the political dynamic here in quebec and
i'll have an interview with jody wilson
raybould about her new book indian in
the cabinet
that's tomorrow from quebec city
thank you donna and from quebec city
global national is going to head to
brampton ontario our final stop ahead of
the federal election
and donna will anchor our extensive
coverage on election night right here on
global television as well as history
global news radio and globalnews.ca
to a developing story in nova scotia
where police are investigating a
terrible loss of life a family of six
including four children between the ages
of 3 and 11 were found dead last evening
after a fire in a camper located in a
rural part of the province
ross lord joins us now from millvale
nova scotia near the scene of this
tragedy
ross farah rcmp say the discovery was
made early sunday evening by someone who
hadn't heard from the family in a while
and came here to check on them
an rcmp spokesperson says a 9-meter
camper in these remote woods near the
nova scotia new brunswick border caught
fire six members of the same family are
dead a man and a woman and four children
between the ages of 3 and 11. my
understanding is it was a a weekend trip
that the family decided to take
the trailer itself is privately owned
and it's on a private plot of land so
it's not like it was at a camp ground or
a campsite or anything like that rcmp
say by the time their members arrived
the fire was out they called the fire
department to stand down
investigators are restricting access but
they say the outside of the camper is
intact
the belief is that it's not a suspicious
fire um but again we're going to remain
on scene we're going to continue to hold
that scene to ensure that if the fire
marshal's office
was to come back with the determination
that the fire was suspicious then we
haven't released those scenes and we
still have that evidence the couple and
their four children are reportedly from
amherst nova scotia the town along with
the local mla have organized a memorial
at a nearby park for people to come and
pay their respects as the rcmp
the fire marshal and the nova scotia
medical examiner's office continue to
investigate
pharah
ross lord in millville nova scotia thank
you ross
a disturbing trend at a canadian
university coming up the multiple
allegations of sexual violence on campus
security is being ramped up in student
residences at ontario's western
university following troubling reports
on social media of sexual violence the
university says there have been four
complaints from students over the past
week officials say they are taking
action including facilitating arrest and
removing students from residents while
investigations continue the alleged
cases do not appear to be connected to
each other
honestly it's pretty scary like i live
right at the end of the street and
although
i'm not in the residence i can only
imagine like what those girls and
any other victims were going through
counseling and gender-based support
services are available to students to
help ensure that they feel safe
still ahead north korea
back with more threats as the regime
flexes its missile might
[Music]
a fast-moving brush fire triggered
evacuations and destroyed several homes
in mendocino county as a tour through
the northern california community sunday
evening more than 13 thousand personnel
are fighting more than a dozen large
active wildfires burning in the state
u.s president joe biden approved a
disaster declaration for california
ahead of today's tour of the fire damage
in the sacramento area
the first commercial flight since the
taliban take over in afghanistan landed
in kabul today the pakistan
international airlines jet touched down
in the afghan capital with just a few
passengers but reportedly returned to
islamabad with about 70 people on board
they're believed to be mostly afghans
including employees with international
organizations and their families after
the withdrawal of uf's troops on august
31st the taliban promised to allow
afghans to leave the country freely
north korea says it successfully
test-fired new long-range cruise
missiles according to state media the
missiles flew 1500 kilometers before
hitting their targets during the test
over the weekend
analysts believe this is possibly the
country's first such weapon with a
nuclear capability nuclear negotiations
between the u.s and north korea stalled
in 2019.
up next i check in with canada's young
voters
what is it going to take to drive more
of them to the polls
[Music]
every election our youngest voters are
consistently among the demographic with
a lower turnout at the ballot box but
the world has changed dramatically since
the last time canadians went to the
polls and issues like affordability
equality and the climate have
politically energized many young voters
i spoke with some students in toronto
about their interest in this election
and what barriers they face
welcome everyone to our election 2021
toronto center candidate's debate
university student hannah nana may be
the debate moderator but i'm not
eligible to vote a refugee to canada
from war-torn syria she is not a citizen
yet but heads up xu votes a voter
engagement campaign at ryerson
university one of the simple rights that
people asked for was voting
a lot of people lost their lives because
of voting and a lot of people lost their
friends and families education and they
were forced to be displaced like myself
so i
see the power and the energy that young
people have in 2015 young voters
reversed a 40-year trend flooding the
polls with 57 voter turnout that dipped
slightly in 2019 but it's still a full
25 percent lower than those 65 to 74.
and this year there's no on-campus
voting due to timing and covet
restrictions catherine carson and lina
mansour are starting a new year
navigating packed schedules in a
pandemic youth have a little bit of
apathy at the moment
and i think that they're unsure about
who they want to vote for and youth are
trying to balance everything their lives
at the moment as well as trying to keep
up with the election despite that they
know what they do want in a government
we need affordability
we're on a campus where a lot of people
are really struggling to pay for their
education a lot of people have lost
their jobs over the pandemic and in
order to build the future we need to
build a present i wish that we were
seeing more in regards to climate change
in regards to access for marginalized
communities whether it's reconciliation
affordability i think this last couple
of years has brought it home for all of
us i think the challenge will be to get
people engaged and recognize that they
can turn those concerns into political
action through voting and reaching young
people is a challenge every election
liberal leader justin trudeau and
conservative leader aaron o'toole prefer
photo ops while ndp leader jagmeet singh
is hoping for a youth uprising
by being the only candidate on tick tock
that you think is the most charismatic
probably just justin trudeau is like a
young
guy that we can kind of like connect
with rather than like the older other
candidates i guess he's actually the
oldest one yeah he's the oldest yeah
justin trudeau is the oldest one yeah
oh my goodness dang actually because
he's like on tick tock too he does all
those videos
reaching young voters is one thing but
walking away with their vote is quite
another
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm farah nasser thanks so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your canada is the
sunrise over lang lake near espanola
ontario we love seeing your canada so
please email us your pictures at viewers
at globalnational.com be sure to tune in
tomorrow when donna freeze in broadcast
from quebec city until next time take
care of yourselves and each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you